FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Thank you so much for coming to
our most recent series of NASA
talks.
Today we have the wonderful
Doctor Kai Goebel,
if I'm pronouncing
that correctly.
Kai holds an MS and
Ph.D and degrees
in mechanical engineering
from Cal Berkeley.
He's the Director of
Prognostic Center of Excellence
at NASA Ames right down
the street from us,
and the Tech Area Lead of
Discovery and Systems Health
Area.
Before joining Ames he
spent a decade at GE
in the corporate R&D, and he
has co-authored more than 250
papers, and holds 18 patents
in the areas of system health
management.
Done a good job.
Most importantly, Kai
is very, very excited
about Germany's recent
win in the World Cup,
and he said that we should
all feel better here in the US
that we only lost
1 to 0 to Germany.
So we should feel
good about that.
Without further ado here is Kai,
and please save your questions
for the end.
And we do have a microphone, so
please talk into the microphone
so the people on the
Live-screen can hear you.
OK.
Thank you.
KAI GOEBEL: Thanks Mary.
I hope nobody's here
with Brazilian descent,
then the 1 0 thing
doesn't quite hold.
We already went over
that so we can skip that,
but I want to quickly
talk a little bit
about our organization.
We have approximately
60 people who
are focusing on this
particular subject area.
We do most of the work for
system health management
for NASA, or at least we
are the lead organization.
And it is mostly low to mid
technology readiness level.
We divide the maturity
of the technology
from one to nine in different
stages, and one to seven
means anything from
conception to prototyping,
and then we leave the
rest to somebody else
to implement and actually
use it in a mission context.
So what we do mostly is provide
a state assessment of systems.
And that includes
technology elements
such as data mining, failure
prediction, fault diagnosis,
decisioning, physics based
modeling, and quantum
computing.
So that's all stuff that
we deal with in DASH,
which stands for Discovery
And Systems Health.
And the overall ideas is to
enable resilience of systems,
and to mitigate off-nominal
kind of conditions.
I'd like to start out with a
definition on the next slides.
Then I'll be talking about why
we care if or whether something
breaks, and then
talk a little bit
about how one would go
about dealing with that,
perhaps preventing it, perhaps
with mitigating something
that has already been broken.
And then I'll give a few
examples from the NASA context.
So systems health
management, it's
the capability to contain,
prevent, detect, diagnose,
predict, respond to, and
recover from conditions
that may interfere with
nominal system operations.
So it's a thing.
What it means is we
are monitoring stuff,
and if there are any kind
of deviations from how
the system should operate then
we want to recognize that,
and we want to do
something about it.
Why do we care if
something breaks?
Well, when we build, or buy,
or operate stuff, by stuff
I really mean equipment,
then there is an expectation
that it should last
for a little while.
So nobody wants to spend a few
hundred dollars on something,
or a few thousand,
or a few million
on something that
immediately breaks.
And oftentimes things
do last a long time.
Sometimes they last even
longer than we expect.
Example might be this
farming equipment.
That thing probably
is 60 or 70 years old,
and farmers are still
using it in the field.
And these are extremely
rugged, and robust, and last
for a long time.
Sometimes things do not last.
And an example might be here.
This Aloha flight
that about 30 years
ago or so had an unfortunate
mishap where part of a fuselage
simply broke off in mid flight.
It just flew off.
And this is a good
argument for always staying
buckled in your seats.
Unfortunately a few
people were not,
so there were a few casualties.
That's bad.
But this is a clear
example of where you really
expect the equipment
to function,
and then you are somewhat
unpleasantly surprised
if it does not.
Obviously we have lots of other
examples where things break
that cause inconveniences,
or that cause even worse,
loss of life.
Everybody has a car.
And we have an expectation
that we can drive to work,
that it doesn't break
down, but we all
know that they can break down.
So we do have somewhat
of a throwaway mentality.
Right?
We use something and
then we stuff it away.
But some things don't
really fit too well
into that kind of mindset.
We are expecting that
for certain safety
relevant equipment that
it actually works well.
So, in particular, I gave
an example on the slide
before for transportation
systems such as airplanes
you really have the
expectation that if you
get in there that it gets
you safely to the other side,
to the next airport.
Similarly with cars, or trains,
or ships, or, in our context,
rockets.
So if you fly a
rocket you really
don't want that
thing to blow up.
In particular, something
of concern for astronauts
who might be sitting
on there, they
have an expectation that that
thing will work reliably.
Power.
Nuclear power plants.
We have an expectation
that those things are safe,
and that they work, and
that there are no accidents
or malfunctions that cause
adverse kind of conditions.
These have happened
in the past of course.
We remember Three Mile Island.
We also remember Fukushima.
If that kind of
equipment malfunctions
there's quickly large
scale kind of consequences,
and we want to avoid that.
Medical equipment.
If you are getting into the
hospital with an emergency
condition you really want the
CT scanner to work, or the MRI.
You don't want that thing
to break down right then
and there.
So you really need that to work.
Another motivation
besides safety
might be that it is
expensive either to replace
or to operate.
Again, in the
context of power you
have these large
stationary gas turbines.
These are huge.
They could be maybe 30 meter
in diameter or something
like that.
And if that breaks down
you cannot operate it.
So the operators are very
unhappy because it costs them
a lot of money, because they
operate on very thin margins.
And it costs a lot
of time to repair it,
because if you have to
crack open a gas turbine
and get to the blade
that has a crack
or something like
that this is a very
expensive kind of undertaking.
Similarly with
wind turbines they
are oftentimes in very remote
places, and they are very tall,
and they're very hard to get to.
And if they fail that costs
you money for one to repair,
but also because you're
not operating it, and not
getting revenue from the
power that you're generating.
Oil and gas, similarly
pipelines, drill rigs,
mining operations, these are
all kind of expensive operations
where you want stuff
to really work.
IT data server farms, I have
a picture here, networks.
You want those
things to operate.
And that may be something that
you're more interested in.
You can't really
accommodate the fact
that the whole thing goes
down due to the cooling system
breaking, or
something like that.
Manufacturing.
You might have robotic
equipment or machinery.
Everything is automated.
And it costs you money if
that stuff breaks down, again,
to repair, and also from loss
of revenue that it's generating.
Security critical
equipment in buildings,
residential or
commercial, you want
to make sure that the security
systems work properly,
that it monitors your house,
that it monitors your property.
And if that breaks
that's bad as well.
So NASA cares about that in
the context of crew decision
support in emergency situations.
Again, you know, if you are
sitting on top of a rocket
and you're ready for
blast off, and you
get an indication that there
might be something wrong
then you have to be pretty sure
to either call off the launch,
or if it has already launched
to eject the astronauts.
And then there's a
very subtle trade
off between the false positives
and the false negatives.
Right, so a false positive is if
you're crying wolf and nothing
actually is wrong that's
a really black eye,
because you're
ejecting the pilots,
and you blow up, you
know, $400 million.
And that doesn't look good.
However, false
negatives are very
unpopular with the astronauts.
And it's mathematically
not possible to really get
both the false positives
and the false negatives,
the likelihood of
both, down to 0.
So you have to find
some sort of trade off,
and the negotiations of
where that set point is,
is a very interesting
one between the operators
and the astronauts.
You also want to ensure
mission completion.
You want to make sure
that crew can come back,
but also if you have
satellites that are oftentimes
very expensive, hundreds
of millions of dollars,
you can't really afford
to put that into space,
and then it just doesn't
do anything there simply
because something breaks
that you didn't anticipate
or that you didn't recognize.
NASA also cares about
cost, increasingly so.
There's an environment
where cost containment
is a big topic.
So for life cycle
management one is
concerned about life
extension to avoid
unscheduled maintenance,
to increase uptime,
to increase launch availability,
to make informed decisions
whether to go or
cancel an operation,
and in general to reduce risk
with the support of go or no-go
decisions.
And what you see
is the launch pad
where the shuttle
used to launch.
And these are fairly
complex kind of beasts.
So it's not just that you put a
rocket somewhere on the ground,
and light a fuse, and
everything goes up.
These are incredibly
complex constructs
that have to work just like
any other complex machinery.
And ultimately you
can use it also
for design improvement where
you feed back the information
about the operation, and also
about the abnormal behavior
into the design.
Here are some
examples where things
didn't go quite as
planned from NASA.
So you see a lot
of satellites here.
Most of them, there's a few
here that we think are on Mars,
but we're not quite sure because
we lost contact and essentially
never were able
to recover those.
There's a few like this
one that had a malfunction,
and then turned into
so-called "fail-safe" mode.
But the fail-safe mode
was such that the battery
was pointed towards the sun,
which then proceeded to cook.
And then once the battery
is cooked the thing is dead.
Apollo 13, we all know
about the mishap there,
and then the space shuttle
also had a few accidents
that we all remember.
So what can one
actually do about it?
Yes.
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: So what are the common
failures, the common types
of faults that cause
those failures?
The fault modes?
KAI GOEBEL: Well, there are
very different fault modes.
Some fault modes that
happen very often
is with the gyroscopes.
So for Kepler, or even
on the space station
there are some
misbehaving gyroscopes
which can be traced down
to the ball bearings that
have certain issues when
you operate them in vacuum
because the lubricant
tends to behave
very different in a gravity
free space than with gravity.
In some other cases you have
communications equipment
that malfunctions, perhaps due
to the presence of radiation.
And so you have single
event upsets, and other kind
of fault modes that
cause some issues.
You may have shorts because
when you're launching something
you have incredible
vibration, and the harnesses
are rattling around.
It might be rubbing
on the fuselage,
and something might short out
that you didn't anticipate.
You may have
software faults where
you have inactions of
different software components
that you didn't anticipate
because you have
some new kind of conditions that
you never encountered before,
and the software was not
meant to handle that.
And so it does something
unanticipated, and it breaks.
So there's really a myriad of
different kinds of fault modes.
And that makes it
also so difficult
to anticipate all
of them, and to care
of all of them ahead of time.
That is of course the idea.
That is what you
would like to do here.
You try to design out
these kind of fault modes
that you know about.
Right, and here
the Rolls Royce is
an example of that
where it was built,
and then something broke,
and then the next generation
they built a more reliable one.
And then something
else broke, and they
tried to take care of that.
And you end up
with two ton beast
which costs you an
incredible amount of money
but which is known to
be very, very reliable.
And that's one of
the trade offs then.
Right, so how much money
do you want to spend,
and how much risk
do you want to incur
operating these kind of things.
You can also build redundancies,
like in this car where
you have sort of the dual tires
in the back where one can blow
and you can still
actually drive this thing.
It doesn't immediately tip over.
So it's an easy
example of redundancy,
but in space systems you
have redundancies everywhere.
Or oftentimes triple
or quadruple redundancy
to account for the fact
that something might break,
but you still need to be
able to operate your system.
And, of course, it
comes at the expense
of more weight, and
size, and, again, cost.
Right, so each kilogram that
you have to bring into space
costs you thousands of dollars.
So you are thinking very
carefully, how much more
redundancy do I put on
these kind of systems.
And right now we are going
towards these nano cube,
or nano satellites,
where you really
can't afford to have
a lot of redundancy
because these are
contradictions in themselves.
So as an alternative
you could try
to recognize impending
failure ahead of time
through analysis and
inference, and then you
could try to handle the
fault ahead of time,
handle your remaining
resources, possibly extend
the life by reducing
the load by moving up
the important experiments that
you still need to carry out,
or the important maneuvers that
you still want to carry out,
or doing some other
active kind of thing.
So in general having information
that something is awry
and going towards a bad
state is a good thing.
Right, so here's a picture
everybody recognizes.
This was the Hurricane Katrina.
This was the path that it
was anticipated to take.
And certainly knowing that is
better than not knowing that,
because you can
evacuate people, and you
can take some sort
of measures to deal
with the kind of situation.
So how does one determine
equipment health?
So here's a cartoon of a rocket.
And the method for that
that we're using really
is one of health,
of human health.
So what we are doing
is we are going,
and we're trying to
actually check out
what is the heartbeat
of the equipment.
And then you go
and say, OK, that's
good information, but what
about the temperature?
Right, so having the kind of
dual independent information
is even more important.
And then maybe I can
put an ECG on my rocket,
and figure out what is the state
of health of the equipment.
Now, if we stay with
the ECG for a moment
you go through a series
of steps to analyze
the health of a patient.
Right, so first you
take your probes here.
Right, and some of
you may have already
had the pleasure or lack thereof
of having to go through that.
Right, and so there
is some gel that
is being put on these things.
And the person who administers
that first checks out
whether those probes
are working well.
Then you have to
interpret the signal.
So you get some wavy
curve out of your ECG,
but what does it actually mean.
So you have to interpret what
does the amplitude mean, what
does the steepness of the curve
here mean, how far does it
dip down, what is the
duration of the pulse,
and then all that kind of stuff.
And you can see that there are
little symbols here that all
have some sort of meaning.
Well, once you have
interpreted that you still
have to figure out whether
that is within normal bounds.
And if not you have to then
give some sort of diagnosis.
Right, the patient is
moderately ill, or hopefully
not, or something else.
Now, given the diagnosis
what is the prognosis?
How much longer do
you have to live?
And then if you know that,
suggest some sort of therapy.
Well, in systems
health management
we do a very similar
thing, except that checking
the probes we call
sensor validation.
Interpreting the ECG signal
is called feature extraction.
So you're trying to
automatically get
some information
out of your sensors.
Next you detect whether
there's some sort
of abnormal condition.
Is everything healthy or not?
So it's sort of a
rough evaluation
of the health of the patient.
Then you do some diagnostics.
You do some prognostics.
So those terms were
essentially adopted.
And then ultimately you
mitigate the situation
in some clever way.
Now, the trick here
is you have to do this
on some inanimate objects
and some equipment,
and you have to
automate all of that.
Right, so there's no
person who does all that.
It's all done in some
sort of automated fashion.
And that's where the
art lies in doing that.
So if we put all
that together then
you have here sort of this
flow diagram of different steps
that we just talked
about that you
go through in a sequential
kind of fashion.
And so, you know, you
pump in raw sensor data.
And these could be temperature
measurements, or vibration
measurements, or
kerns, or voltages,
or any other kinds
of information
that you get from real sensors.
So from that you
actually then have
to extract kind of
information after
you have validated that the
information is actually good.
Right, if you have a bad
sensor all the inference really
isn't going to help you because
it will just produce garbage.
You then extract features.
I'm going to show an example
of what that might be.
And based on those features
then you make a determination
whether you have
an anomaly or not,
and the output of that are
warnings or alerts that
indicate here is some
anomalous kind of condition.
But it doesn't say what it is.
It just says there's
something wrong.
What is wrong is being
done in the next step.
So it's the next
step of analysis
where you figure out, OK, this
is the particular fault mode.
So coming back to your
question, you don't just
want to know that
something is wrong,
but you want to know
what exactly is wrong.
Right?
Do I have to focus
on my gyroscope,
or do I have to focus on my
communications equipment,
or do I have to
focus on my payload.
And it makes a big difference
in dealing with the situation.
Then you go into prognostics.
You want to estimate, well,
OK, something is wrong,
and I know that's my
communications equipment.
When will I completely
lose functionality?
And that is a
function of how you
are using the equipment
in the future.
If you are loading
it very heavily
it might go more quickly.
If you're not beating
on it very hard then
it might last a little longer.
And then ultimately you're
doing some fault accommodation
where you're taking
some corrective action.
And that can be a very
complicated kind of thing
because you may have
multiple objectives that you
are trying to satisfy
at the same time.
And so now we're getting
into optimization routines,
and often time
multiple objective
optimization where you
end up with a large number
of optimal solutions,
and then you still
have to select one of those.
All right, so let's go
through a quick example
for each one of those.
I think that it might
make it a little bit more
clear what we're talking about.
So in sensor validation you have
some data from some sensors.
Right, so these could be
pressure sensors and flow
sensors.
And you go back to the physics,
and one could, for example,
build some analytical
redundancy where
you know that pressure
and flow are related
to each other in
some sort of fashion.
And the pressure
upstream of a pipe
is related to the pressure
downstream of a pipe.
And if you have a
change in the pressure
then that has to be correlated
to how the pressure is upstream
based on the physics
of the system.
And one can build
some sort of analytics
that describe how the
readings are expected
to change if you have
certain changes in one
part of the system.
And so it can be expressed
with a few equations.
And then one would detect if
there is an inconsistency,
and you flag that
kind of sensor,
and say, OK, I'm not going
to trust that one anymore.
I have to rely on
the other ones.
And I can still
continue my analysis,
but I have weeded
out the bad sensor.
And that is actually
an important step
in the overall concept.
Similarly to the
ECG, you don't want
to perform your ECG
with some bad probes.
It just doesn't make sense.
And here it's important that
that is done automatically
because there is
nobody standing there.
There's nobody standing on
the wind turbine checking
those probes on a daily
basis, or on an hourly basis.
It has to be done automatically.
So next you have to
extract features.
So the question is if you
have a bunch of data points
in a way where you have,
this is the magnitude
of something, maybe pressure,
or temperature, or vibration,
and here you have time, you
get these data points in,
but what do they mean?
Where's the information.
And there's a lot of signal
processing techniques
that can be employed
to really pull out
information out of raw data.
So you're not just looking
at the magnitude, which
of course can be
important information,
but there's more than that.
Right?
You can extract information
also in the frequency domain,
or in the chaotic domain,
or in any other domain.
So you can transform the
data into a different domain.
A Fourier transform
is an example there,
or a wavelet transform.
And then extract features
in that kind of domain.
So let's see.
So we want the features to be
explainable in physical terms,
mathematically definable.
We, of course, want
of them not only
to look pretty, but have some
sort of meaning with regards
to the fault that I'm
trying to diagnose.
It should ideally
be uncorrelated
with other features.
It should be insensitive
to extraneous variables,
and also not too
expensive to measure
if I have limited computational
resources on my asset.
Which may not be as
much of a concern
if you have a
ground based system.
But if you have a space
based system, again,
if you want to put a
supercomputer on a nano
satellite that's not
going to be so easy.
And then of course you can
derive features of features
where you are extracting
information from the features,
or you're combining them in
some sort of smart fashion.
And there's a few
examples here where
you have various
statistics moments,
or combine them in
some other fashion.
And one can also automate that.
So you don't need to necessarily
know all of that ahead of time
what you want to do.
You can have
learning algorithms,
or machine learning
algorithms that
explore the space of features
and find new features for you.
So you could use
genetic programming,
or genetic algorithms, or
other optimization tools that
find combinations of
different features.
And I already
talked about Fourier
and transform [INAUDIBLE].
So now we have only
gone to the point
of actually deriving features.
Now I actually have to
make a determination
of whether something
is anomalous or not.
And how would I do that?
So the question
here is in this data
set I'm just looking at
the last four data points.
Are those in the normal
range or are those abnormal?
So who thinks these are normal?
Who thinks they are abnormal?
OK, I need a brave soul here.
And who has no opinion?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
OK.
All right.
Ha, ha, ha.
OK, maybe it's hard
to tell, right.
So we don't really know.
So one example of a tool
that one could use here,
and there's literally
hundreds of them,
is the Rank
Permutation Test, which
transforms the data in
some sort of ranking space,
and then performs a hypothesis
test in that rank space.
So you determine
a null hypothesis,
which is the data
are abnormal or not.
Then you choose some sort
of test statistics, which
in this case here
is the sum of ranks.
Then you compute
the test statistic
for original observations,
permute the observations,
recalculate the test statistic,
and repeat that 1,000 times
or so, and then you
either accept or reject
the null hypothesis that
this is normal data.
And if you do that many
times, like here, right.
So you just sample your
space before those.
You do this over, and
over, and over again,
and you compare those data
that you sample with the ones
that you're investigating.
And then after you
do this 1,000 times,
and I'm not going to do
it many more times I hope,
you calculate the
statistics, and you
look where are your
data points here,
which is where the
line is, and you
can see that most
of the data actually
is on the right
side of that curve.
And if you calculate
that it turns out
that there's a 99.3% almost
chance that this data is not
normal, which is not obvious
when you look at the data
as they were originally.
They were sort of
within the bounds,
but they were just
slightly clustered outside.
And so that is an example of how
one could make a determination
that data are abnormal or not.
Obviously where you put the
threshold is completely up
to you.
Right, so if you want
to have a 99.999%
confidence that something
is abnormal or not
then you would have
to wait for the signal
to become more clear.
So now that we know that
something is not normal
we want to go and analyze
the data with regards
to the fault mode.
And that can be done through
a number of different ways.
One will be to have some
sort of inference systems
which could be
implemented through a rule
based system, where you have
different kinds of rules, where
if A is B than C.
And you can have
a number of different rules.
And you could see whether any
of those rules are triggered.
And then you could make
an inference with regards
to the particular root cause.
You also have to deal with
the fact that some of the data
may be not completely crisp, or
that the fact that the data are
very, very close to a threshold
just on one side of it
may result in your diagnostics
to fluctuate a lot.
And so you have to deal with
uncertainty in some fashion.
And there's different
ways to do that.
You could do it with, in
a probabilistic sense,
you could use fuzzy logic.
You could use a number
of different ways
to deal with uncertainty.
And then the term fuzzy
logic is sometimes
used to express that nothing
serious is being done,
but in fact it is a methodology
that you have to step through.
And there's very clear
rules how to deal
with information in
some specific way.
And this just shows
an example of that
where you have some facts where
X is A and Y is B, and a rule,
and you have to
come to some sort
of a conclusion
about the result.
And this is just a visual
of how you go about that,
and then you end up with
geometric constructs,
and you have to take out some
actual crisp decision out
of that.
And there's some
methodology to it
that you go through
to accomplish that.
OK, now that we know that my
communication system is bad
now I want to know
at what point does
it fail so that I have
lost complete function
of that equipment.
And that is done in prognostics.
Now you're trying to
estimate how much time
do I have until that happens.
And so there's a
graph here that shows
that, where you have time
here, and the health here,
and the health
deteriorates oftentimes
in some sort of
nonlinear fashion.
And you're predicting it
at different time points
how much time do I have
until I reach a threshold.
This would be my end
of life threshold.
How much time do I have
until that happens?
And so that is done again
using some mathematical tools
where you're not just
waving your hand,
or you're using some straight
line extrapolation and saying,
OK, it may be here in
some time in the future.
You have to account for the
fact that your system may behave
in some non-linear fashion,
which, again, is driven
by the physics of the system.
And so you have to encapsulate
that in some smart fashion.
That could be done
either by using data.
So you could have a data
driven kind of approach
where you have
observed your system,
or a fleet of
systems many times,
and you have all kinds of
trajectories that inform you
about how the
system deteriorates.
And then you can build, again
with machine learning tools,
a representation of the
deterioration over time.
Or you have to
build a model that
is based on the
physics of the system
that you're using to
express the expected change
of the degradation
of the system.
And that you have to do when
your fleet is not very large.
So that is something that
we at NASA have very often.
Your fleet size is
not 20,000 or 100,000.
Sometimes it's one.
And so you can't blow
up 35 test rockets just
to see what happens
when my case cracks.
It's too expensive.
Or you cannot wait for
that to happen either.
So really have to wrap your
head around what is actually
happened at the
physical level when
there's a crack in
my rocket casing,
and how is that
growing as a function
of the internal temperatures
and pressures of the rocket.
So another example is
here on the launch pad
that I showed
earlier, you have some
in these spheres here,
your liquid propellant.
It's oxygen and hydrogen.
And so there is a 1.5 kilometer
line here to this oxygen tank.
And then if you go out
here's the launch pad,
and on the other side, far on
the other side is the hydrogen.
And you want to keep those
two really far apart.
And you want to wait
until the very end
before you get them
close together,
because for obvious reasons
it's very dangerous.
So you also want to make
sure that any of these pumps
and valves are working.
Right, once you actually
say, OK, system is a go,
OK, now we're pumping 100,000
liters of liquid oxygen
into the external tank
of the space shuttle,
or whatever vehicle
you have there,
you don't want to
get into a situation
where you say, oh, sorry,
my valve is stuck right now.
Can we scrub the launch?
That immediately costs
you a lot of money,
and makes a lot of
people very unhappy.
And your launch
window may no longer
be open because of weather or
other kinds of considerations.
And so it really needs to be
available when you need it.
So you need to
have an assessment
of the goodness of the health
of these kinds of pieces
of the equipment.
And so here are some
examples of valves,
I'm not sure how
well you are seeing
that, or pumps that
are being used.
Some of them are pretty old.
Some of these tanks have been
used during the Apollo era.
So that was a long time ago.
So the pump that I just
showed can be modeled.
Right, so here's just
a cartoon of that,
but fundamentally what you
have is just a plug here.
And here's the pipe
with the fluid flow.
And if the plug advances, then
the fluid flow is interrupted.
If it goes up, then
obviously something can flow.
And you do that by
opening the valve
by pumping in some
pneumatic air in here that
lifts the piston up
against a return spring.
And there is a port up
here that opens and allows
the air to escape.
And if everything fails
this particular valve
has a fail-safe of closed.
Right, so the return spring
then forces the plug down,
and it interrupts the pressure.
Now, seems extremely simple,
but if you have some wear here
then you have some
leakage along the plug.
Or if you have a wear along
the piston and the wall
that's no good because then not
enough pressure can be built up
to open the valve.
Similarly, if the
return spring gets weak
or if there's some leakage
across the top port
you have some consequences that
you somehow have to deal with.
And so even for a
very simple component
like that you have half a dozen
fault modes that you can model,
and that you can account
for, and that one can use.
One still has to figure out what
is my end of life criterion.
And you can go back
to the specifications
and say, OK, the valve
has to open or close
within a certain time frame.
So let's say the valve has
to open in five seconds.
And usually if everything works
well it opens in 1.5 seconds.
But as things are
degrading you see
that it opens slower and slower,
and eventually will no longer
meet your functional spec.
That's just to
say that you don't
have to wait for something
to explode or something
catastrophic to happen
to define a failure.
What we actually need is a
mathematically quantifiable
threshold that we
can work towards,
and that we can define
how far away are we
from that threshold.
And that's actually
very important
to ultimately calculate
what is my remaining life.
And then you go
into your modeling.
You express your valve
state through positions
and velocities, and gas mass
above and below the piston.
And then you do some state
derivatives and inputs.
Has anybody seen anything
like that before?
All right, we have a
few engineers here.
Excellent.
And then you do physics 101.
Right, so you have
some piston movement,
and that kind of stuff.
And then you do physics 201.
You express your gas flows,
and that kind of stuff.
There's nothing
magic about here.
This is all textbook
stuff, right?
But it actually gets
employed to express
the expected behavior
of your system.
And so everything that
you learned in physics
in high school and later
in college actually gets
used here.
And then you go and look at what
kind of sensors do you have?
And from that you
can then model what
is your expected
behavior of your system.
Right, how should
your valve open
and close based on the
expression of the physics?
And then you can
also model damage.
So you may have
increase in friction,
or you may have a decrease
in friction due to wear.
And all that then ultimately,
which is expressed down here,
leads to changed
characteristics of the opening
or the closing of the valves.
And that is expressed here.
Based on the
particular fault mode
you see that these curves change
as a function of the cycles,
in this particular case
of operating of the valve.
And then you still
have to deal with, OK,
now that I know what my
state is now how will it
change in the future?
And so you have to extrapolate
that out into the future.
And one particular
technique that can be used
is called a particle filter.
Many of you may have heard
of a [INAUDIBLE] filter.
A particle filter is
something like that.
So it's not a physical
thing where, you know, like
in your vacuum where
you have your filter.
It's a mathematical tool.
And I'm not going to go into
details of how to use that,
but the whole point
is that you are
going into the future
with different kinds
of possible path to then express
your end of life prediction
through a probability mass
function, in which it then
can approximate with a
probability density function.
So there's not just one
point that you're getting,
unfortunately,
because you may have
a lot of uncertainty due to
your sensor measurements,
or your model is bad, and
your future load predictions.
So your actual remaining
life will be a curve,
and can be approximated with the
probability density function.
But you can still
choose, as I choose
here the meeting of
the curve, or, again,
if I want to be
conservative I can
be on that side of the curve
and take the extremely risk
averse point.
But the point of that
is you buy yourself
that much time to
actually do something.
So you don't have to wait until
it actually breaks, and you
don't have to replace the valve
on a conservative schedule
every 10 cycles.
You actually know
with high confidence
that you can operate this
thing safely that many times
without an expectation that
something bad is happening.
And that's the beauty
of that approach.
And then of course
you're repeating that.
As you're using it you're
collecting more information
about the current state
of health of the system.
You're updating your expectation
of what is happening.
And if you did
everything right then
this curve actually
will not move.
You're just moving through time.
And the PDF here will just
get steeper and more narrow
because you're taking
out more uncertainty.
And then you're going to
calculate your performance.
And then ultimately you
do something about it.
And, again, you're using
different kinds of techniques
to go about that.
And what you're doing
with information,
you have 50 cycles
left, is different
than if I tell you that
I have five cycles left.
Or if we express it
in time, if I tell you
that your system will break
in 30 milliseconds there's
no point scheduling maintenance
to accommodate that, right?
If I tell you that your system
will break in three months,
well, now I can
schedule maintenance
when it's convenient for me.
If I have the guy go out to
the wind turbine in two months
anyway, well, maybe
he should look
at the other one next to
it, and that saves me money.
Or, again, if I have
30 milliseconds left
I go immediately into a
fail-safe mode reflexively.
If I have three hours left
I can think about mission
rescheduling or
re-planning, and, again,
do the right kind of thing.
All right.
So these kind of concepts
we implemented here
on our rover concept.
This is sort of the monster
truck of the rovers.
And we used the Nexus S for part
of the instrumentation suite.
Obviously as you know it has a
whole bunch of sensors on there
which is extremely convenient.
It also has communications,
wireless communication
and storage on there.
And we have taken
advantage of that.
You just plop that
thing on there,
and in principle
you could use that
for all kinds of
different things, right,
not just for rovers,
but you could put it
on many different
types of equipment
to enable the kind of reasoning
that I just described.
In this particular case
the fault modes of interest
that we're interested in were
motor winding deterioration,
battery charge depletion,
capacity degradation,
some parasitic electrical load,
increased mechanical friction,
and we built some fault
injection mechanisms
onto the rover.
So sometimes you have to
wait a long, long time
until something bad happens.
So here since we didn't want to
wait 30 years for the bearing
to go bad or something like that
we helped things a little bit,
and built in mechanisms that
put in a parasitic load, which
resulted in the
battery discharging
faster and degrading faster.
And so it's a nice
validation tool
that allows you to test out
different kind of concepts,
also for mitigation, which
are important in sort
of an autonomous context.
Right, so if you have
a rover go around,
and it experiences
some deterioration,
well, what do you want to do?
I mean, this is our self
driving car fundamentally.
Right?
So if your self driving
car is degrading, well,
are you going to do
something about it or not?
And the right answer
is, yes, of course I
want to do something
about it, right?
So what do I want
to do about it?
And again it depends.
And how you go
about that has to be
done in a mathematically
rigorous fashion, which
can be described,
for example, using
different types of
optimization techniques.
You have to build a
simulator into your tool that
explores different kinds
of mitigating options,
and then implements
the right solution.
So on a self
driving car or rover
it could be don't go 75 miles an
hour, go only 55 miles an hour.
It buys you enough time to
actually get to the target.
Or it could be, well, we have
to cut the scenic route short,
and we can't do
these way points.
You know, we have to cut a few
off, and get you back earlier.
But at least we know that it's
important to you to get back,
and we can satisfy that
particular constraint,
and so on.
And so that's shown here where
we have different way points.
This is the route
that we wanted to do.
Here we found that
there was a fault.
And the mission
re-planner then said,
OK, I have to cut out
this way point here,
and I'm going straight
back, but I'm going back
with some margin that allows
you to complete the mission.
Some examples here.
What we use, the
techniques that I just
described for rocket
engine test stands,
for robotic spaceflights,
aeronautics.
Right, so the first A in
NASA actually is Aeronautics.
So we do a lot of work with
aircraft and other kinds
of things that fly
within the atmosphere.
Composite shrouds.
ISS.
And et cetera.
All right.
So what did I just show you?
We use system health management.
And we understand it as
a systematic engineering
discipline that is used
to monitor systems,
to determine whether
things run as expected,
or whether and when
they might break.
And the core elements within
that suite of techniques,
or that umbrella are monitoring,
modeling behavior, recognizing
anomalous behavior,
predicting time
to some sort of
boundary condition,
and ultimately also
mitigating that.
Some of the remaining
challenges that we still
have-- Not everything
is done-- are
to implement learning
and adaptive systems.
So for us space is still
the final frontier.
We actually don't
know what's out there
and how systems
will be behaving.
So we have to build
in a system that
can adapt to those unanticipated
changes and do the right thing.
Software complexity.
V&V certification--
That may be something
that resonates with you as
well-- is something that
is increasingly a
challenge to make sure
that our complex systems
will be behaving properly.
Uncertainty management.
So nothing is deterministic.
Right, everything
has uncertainty.
How do I properly express,
or represent, and encapsulate
my uncertainty, and deal with
that in a decision making
context?
And then ultimately
decision making itself.
Right, tie the information
back to the benefit
that you're trying
to generate, which
could be completing the mission,
or bringing the astronauts
safely back.
And there's oftentimes
competing kind of objectives
that have to be
properly dealt with.
And with that I would
like to close here.
And if you have any questions
I'd be happy to answer those.
AUDIENCE: So what
are some strategies
for dealing with software
failures, where the things that
go wrong might not be as
predictable as mechanical
failure where you know what
the faults are going to be?
KAI GOEBEL: Right.
So obviously you want to, again,
design out as many as you can.
We think that
software health is one
of the next really
emerging, important topics.
We have already
looked into that.
You can monitor certain things.
Right, you can
monitor the number
of threads, or your
communications.
And you can monitor memory
usage, and all that kind
of stuff, and relate that
back to the applications
that you're running,
and have some sort
of feeling for whether
things are right or wrong.
So in that sense
actually you could
use some of the concepts
that are explained here
in a mechanical kind of
context also for software.
That alone will
not get you there.
So what we have to
do is explore how
you would go about
autonomous V&V actually.
Right, so as you have to
implement new routines
on the fly you have to
perform V&V on the fly also.
And so there's
some formal methods
that one can explore
to tackle that,
but that is definitely a
not completed topic yet.
AUDIENCE: OK, so how does
your like on board health
monitoring hardware
look like if you
want to do the autonomous V&V?
KAI GOEBEL: How does it what?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: The on board, the
health monitoring hardware,
because everything is automated.
So what kind of processors,
how many processors
are you using to run
your health monitoring?
KAI GOEBEL: For
conceptual things
you can use whatever
you want, right?
But if you want to
fly something in space
it has to be rat
hardened, and usually you
run some processors
that are 20 years old,
or something like that.
So you're not going to get
the state of the art for that.
AUDIENCE: But the
operations you show
looked pretty
computation intensive
if you want to do
that on board, right?
KAI GOEBEL: Yes.
And so we will have
to push for making
more resources available
on board for these things.
And we expect that they will.
I mean, clearly
the expectation is
that more functionality will
be assumed through software,
and that it's
exponentially growing.
And I don't see
that the curve will
be flattening any time soon.
Well, thank you very much.
[CLAPPING]